lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
revisar la regla del producto que tú
quizás viste hace algún tiempo para
obtener la regla de integración por
partes que puede ser vista como el
inversa de la regla el producto
integración por partes consideremos
entonces una función formada por el
producto de dos funciones la función fx
por la función de x y vamos a derivar
este producto vamos a sacar la derivada
con respecto a x vamos acá la diva con
respecto a x de fx porque x esto que es
igual esto es igual
aplicando la regla del producto a la
derivada del primero por el segundo
derivada de f dejar poner lo mejor en
azul
efe prima es en ese azul va a ser igual
entonces f prima de x la derivada del
primero por x es en ese mismo color
déjame cambiarlo por gd x más la primera
más fx por la derivada de la segunda más
fx por la derivada de gx por g prima de
x hemos aplicado la regla del producto
aquí la derivada del primero por el
segundo más el segundo por la eba del
primero ok vamos a tomar la anti
derivada a ambos lados de esta expresión
qué pasa si tomamos la anti derivada de
la derivada con respecto x de fx porque
x pues es directamente fx
gx por el momento nos olvidamos de la
constante integración y esto que va a
ser igual bueno vamos a tomar la anti
derivada del lado derecho esto va a ser
la anti derivada de f prima de x por gt
x
de x más la anti derivada de fx x
que prima de x
y por supuesto de equis queremos ahora
despejar esta expresión queremos
despejar esta anti derivada y para eso
tenemos que restar esta expresión de
aquí vamos a restar a ambos lados esta
expresión de aquí entonces que tenemos
del lado izquierdo tenemos
fx por de x menos menos la anti derivada
de f prima de x
déjame ponerlo en rosa en el rosa que
tiene originalmente por gd x
de equis y esto va a ser igual lo que
queríamos despejar anti derivada de fx
por prima de x
de x vamos a intercambiar ambos lados de
la igualdad para que quede clara la
fórmula voy a copiar copiar y pegar
ok lado izquierdo quedaría esto acá y
esto también voy a copiar y pegar del
lado derecho
y aquí lo tenemos
esta es la fórmula de integración por
partes
voy a ponerle su marco como aparece en
los libros de texto para resaltar esta
fórmula de integración por partes y esta
fórmula establece que si vas a integrar
el producto de una función por la
derivada de otra función esto va a ser
igual a todo esto y tú podrías decir
bueno esto no es muy útil primero tienes
que identificar una función y la
derivada otra función y luego aquí
tenemos que encontrar otra anti derivada
pero vamos a ver en futuros vídeos que
esta es una regla que nos va a ser muy
útil para encontrar anti derivadas de
cierto tipo de funciones